Lucia:oops
Lucia: Oops.
Jake:哎你是
Jake: Hey, you...
Lucia:我快没电了
Lucia: I'm almost out of power.
Lucia:我靠
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:不是哈哈
Lucia: No, haha.
Lucia:不是啥情况
Lucia: No, what’s going on?
Lucia:我少按一个板
Lucia: I missed a panel.
Lucia:别这玩意没安好让我给拆了
Lucia: Don't, this thing wasn't installed properly and I disassembled it.
Lucia:never mind
Lucia: Never mind.
Lucia:先这样吧
Lucia: Let's leave it for now.
Lucia:不是是要压到底吗
Lucia: No, should it be pressed all the way down?
Lucia:i look
Lucia: I look.
Lucia:他亲一下
Lucia: He kissed me.
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia:What
Lucia: What?
Lucia:好家伙
Lucia: Oh boy.
Jake:再来一次
Jake: One more time.
Jake:再来一次啊
Jake: One more time, okay?
Jake:再来一次
Jake: One more time.
Lucia:怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Jake:刚刚我
Jake: Just now I...
Jake:走一半关了
Jake: It shut off halfway through.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:要不做个狗
Jake: How about we make a dog?
Jake:啊我们一起来做狗吧
Jake: Ah, let's make a dog together.
Jake:露亚 对露亚来指导一下
Jake: Lucia, yeah, guide us a bit.
Lucia:可以啊我我这个马上快完工了
Lucia: Sure, I'm almost done with this.
Jake:好 好嘞
Jake: Alright, good.
Lucia:III believe so
Lucia: I believe so.
Jake:我们来quarter一下
Jake: Let's quarter it.
Lucia:不是但是他
Lucia: No, but he...
Lucia:嗯我觉得还是有什么地方好像
Lucia: Hmm, I think there's still something...
Shure: 雨轩老师唱功了得
Shure: Yuxuan's singing skills are amazing.
Jake:好像不太准了
Jake: Seems a bit off.
Shure: 雨轩老师还有什么想唱的歌
Shure: Yuxuan, any other songs you want to sing?
Lucia:对就这个
Lucia: Yeah, that's it.
Lucia:这玩意他应该能但是其实也没事
Lucia: He should be able to, but actually, it doesn't matter.
Shure: 我尽量的都帮你弹一弹
Shure: I'll try my best to play along.
Lucia:实在不行就不安里面
Lucia: If it doesn't work, just leave it out.
Lucia:结果把这冲墙
Lucia: In the end, it broke the wall.
Jake:哎这个为什么
Jake: Hey, why is this...
Lucia:然后他就是
Lucia: And then it...
Jake:不行不行我试试看
Jake: No, no, let me try.
Lucia:你有强迫症啊哈
Lucia: You have OCD, huh?
Jake:呃可以有一点
Jake: Uh, maybe a bit.
Lucia:OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake:这个首先这个是对上的对吧
Jake: First, this is aligned, right?
Lucia:对这是对上的
Lucia: Yes, it's aligned.
Lucia:因为呢一会我们把它方便装进去
Lucia: Because later, it will be easier to install.
Lucia:也不用拼那么死
Lucia: No need to fit it so tightly.
Lucia:而且就是过几天可能还要把它拆开
Lucia: Also, we might need to take it apart in a few days.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Jake:哦对哎这也依了半天哈哈哈
Jake: Oh right, this has been like this for half a day, haha.
Jake:这个可能是放后面
Jake: This might go in the back.
Lucia:这玩意怎么又掉下来了
Lucia: Why did this fall again?
Lucia:就是它这
Lucia: It's just that this...
Jake:哪个是放后面来着
Jake: Which one goes at the back again?
Lucia:呃这个上面有说明书
Lucia: Uh, there's a manual on top.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:就是这个这框这样拼的
Lucia: It's this one, this frame goes together like this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:然后所以我觉得吧
Lucia: So I think...
Lucia:就是这个有有底下有这一条的
Lucia: It's the one with this strip on the bottom.
Jake:对应该是挂准这样的
Jake: Yeah, it should hang like this.
Lucia:就是他好像是在这就是有一条的
Lucia: It seems like there's a strip here.
Lucia:跟这个连着
Lucia: It's connected to this.
Lucia:你觉得呢
Lucia: What do you think?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:是这意思不
Lucia: Is that what it means?
Jake:我试试
Jake: Let me try.
Lucia:没事没事我会把它修好了
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, I'll fix it.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia:对吧
Lucia: Right?
Lucia:所以理论上应该是就是不是你
Lucia: So theoretically, it should be... not you.
Lucia:你看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Jake:哈哈我知道我知道我知道
Jake: Haha, I know, I know, I know.
Jake:理论上是这么回事
Jake: Theoretically, that's how it works.
Lucia:对理论上他应该是这是跟这走的OK
Lucia: Yeah, theoretically, it should go with this. OK.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: Then...
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia:但是反正总之就是我安进去之后吧
Lucia: But anyway, when I put it in...
Lucia:他他他总是有哪不太对劲
Lucia: There's always something a bit off.
Lucia:就好像是长或者宽就对
Lucia: It seems like the length or width is right.
Lucia:然后这样把它推进去
Lucia: Then you push it in like this.
Lucia:对哦
Lucia: Yeah, oh.
Lucia:但是就是我刚才推它推不到里边
Lucia: But when I just pushed it, it wouldn't go all the way in.
Lucia:它会就有一点在外边露着
Lucia: It sticks out a bit.
Lucia:就它没有办法完全融这个抽屉
Lucia: It can't fully integrate into the drawer.
Lucia:融入不了柜子哦
Lucia: It doesn't fit into the cabinet.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia:等会我先把底下这个修好啊
Lucia: Wait, let me fix this bottom part first.
Lucia:好稍微按一下就好了
Lucia: Okay, just press it a bit and it'll be fine.
Lucia:哈哈这被咱俩折腾完
Lucia: Haha, after we mess with it...
Lucia:这玩意还能用不
Lucia: Can this thing still be used?
Jake:要不就是空心的嘛对吧总有
Jake: Or maybe it's hollow, right? There's always...
Jake:乞丐方案
Jake: Beggar's plan.
Jake:还有板吗
Jake: Do we still have boards?
Jake:还有看到
Jake: Can you still see?
Lucia:有吧
Lucia: I think so.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:但是接下来就是那三个配套的抽屉
Lucia: But next are those three matching drawers.
Lucia:其实就完事了
Lucia: Actually, it's done.
Lucia:这还挺好装的
Lucia: This is quite easy to assemble.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:都是一些榫牟结构
Lucia: They are all mortise and tenon structures.
Lucia:差不多就这样但是再稍微轻点
Lucia: Almost done but just be a bit more gentle.
Lucia:因为我后面装的不是很使劲
Lucia: Because I didn't use much force when assembling the back.
Lucia:我怕太用劲把压的那啥了对
Lucia: I'm afraid if I use too much force, it might press down too hard, right?
Lucia:你先按要不先
Lucia: You press first, or...
Jake:按上面的
Jake: Press the top part.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:哎就直接直接
Jake: Yeah, just directly, directly.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Lucia:就总觉得有点有哪里不对
Lucia: It always feels like something is off.
Lucia:哎哎
Lucia: Hey, hey.
Jake:这个像这么回事
Jake: This looks more like it.
Jake:哎不像了
Jake: Oh, not really.
Lucia:哈哈哈又不像了
Lucia: Haha, now it doesn't look like it again.
Jake:像应该还是像的
Jake: It should look like it though.
Jake:可能得是
Jake: Maybe it needs to...
Jake:这个稍微是不是出来一点呀
Jake: Should this part come out a bit more?
Lucia:是不是卡的呀
Lucia: Is it stuck?
Lucia:好像是这么回事吧
Lucia: Seems like that's the issue.
Lucia:挺好挺好挺好
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Lucia:就这样就这样就这样嗯
Lucia: Just like this, just like this, just like this.
Jake:大成功大成功
Jake: Big success, big success.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:每天都在成功
Jake: We're succeeding every day.
Lucia:每天都在成功对
Lucia: Succeeding every day, right.
Lucia:谢谢柯欣
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Alice:我觉得中间它好像断开了
Alice: I think it broke in the middle.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: It's not a big issue.
Alice:就这
Alice: Just this.
Lucia:这里就再把它再按一下就好了
Lucia: Just press it again here.
Lucia:因为这个东西他都插进去
Lucia: Because this part needs to be inserted.
Lucia:他没有螺丝
Lucia: It doesn't have screws.
Lucia:所以就是这个
Lucia: So, it's this.
Lucia:这个地方如果就不能太使劲
Lucia: You can't use too much force here.
Lucia:如果太使劲的话
Lucia: If you use too much force,
Lucia:他这个这个地方就会就会脱出来
Lucia: this part will come off.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:外面在干啥
Alice: What's happening outside?
Lucia:稍等一下
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia:哎看看这是他就会出来
Lucia: Look, it will come out.
Jake:好去吧
Jake: Okay, go ahead.
Alice:他们在干嘛
Alice: What are they doing?
Jake:他们在唱歌
Jake: They are singing.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia:啊嗯
Lucia: Ah, yeah.
Lucia:外面可以卡拉OK吗
Lucia: Can they do karaoke outside?
Jake:对他们在唱歌啊
Jake: Yes, they are singing.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:可以一会啊
Jake: Yes, go ahead.
Jake:后面对去吧
Jake: Let's move on.
Jake:哎这怎么对不上了
Jake: Hey, why doesn't this fit?
Lucia:可以对上
Lucia: It can fit.
Jake:对上了对上了
Jake: It's fitting now.
Lucia:就是要因为它都是一些塑料板
Lucia: It's because it's all plastic panels.
Lucia:对然后把它插个大概进去就完事了
Lucia: Yes, then just insert it in about there and it's done.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:稍等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia:这好像
Lucia: This seems like...
Lucia:这个没有
Lucia: This doesn't have...
Lucia:这个就是理论上它要按紧
Lucia: This should be pressed tightly in theory.
Jake:哦好行
Jake: Oh, okay.
Lucia:然后稍等
Lucia: Then wait.
Lucia:我先把这个放哪去了
Lucia: Let me put this first.
Jake:理伦上要按紧咱就不按紧
Jake: In theory, we should press it tightly, but we won't.
Lucia: : 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia:因为这个摁紧环还有点难摁
Lucia: Because pressing this ring tightly is a bit difficult.
Jake:好的咱就不按紧
Jake: Okay, we won't press it tightly.
Lucia:嗯 前面这个地方
Lucia: Hmm, the front part here.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:对就就最下面上
Lucia: Yes, just the bottom.
Lucia:刚才有最下面拉垮
Lucia: The bottom part was loose earlier.
Lucia:好像有点
Lucia: Seems like there's a bit...
Lucia:哪里卡着了似的
Lucia: Something seems stuck somewhere.
Jake:你
Jake: You...
Lucia:sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Lucia:对就是它这还要卡一下
Lucia: Yeah, this needs to be stuck here.
Lucia:因为这就是要把这个东西卡也
Lucia: Because it needs to latch this thing here.
Lucia:卡到这一层
Lucia: To this level.
Lucia:他也是那个塑料壳那个地方
Lucia: It's also at the plastic case part.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Lucia:我也想看
Lucia: I also want to see.
Lucia:嗯对着这样子
Lucia: Yeah, like this.
Lucia:嗯对好了前面点
Lucia: Yeah, that's it, a bit forward.
Lucia:然后这个也是一个道理
Lucia: And this is the same principle.
Lucia:同理可证
Lucia: Same proof.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh
Lucia:妈呀
Lucia: Oh my
Lucia:他好像对我的说法不是很满意
Lucia: He doesn't seem too satisfied with my explanation.
Jake:他不要被证明
Jake: He doesn't want proof.
Lucia:没事充电宝掉了没事
Lucia: It's fine, the power bank fell, no worries.
Jake:我们今晚
Jake: Tonight,
Jake:做什么呀
Jake: what are we doing?
Jake:薄荷嗯
Jake: Mint, hmm?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:现在就做
Jake: Let's do it now.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 好了差不多吧反正
Lucia: Alright, that's about it, anyway.
Lucia: 先这样吧啊后面两个没插进去
Lucia: Let's leave it like this, the last two didn't go in.
Lucia:好了
Lucia: Done.
Lucia: 这个您怎么放的来着
Lucia: How did you place this again?
Tasha:好还有肉松小贝
Tasha: Okay, and some meat floss cake.
Tasha:想吃哪一个
Tasha: Which one do you want?
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: Either is fine.
Lucia:两个天菜都很好吃
Lucia: Both are very delicious.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Lucia:就这样吧
Lucia: Let's leave it at that.
Lucia:管他呢
Lucia: Whatever.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:好了胜昨了
Lucia: Alright, it's done.
Jake:挺好啊
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:应该是没有合警他歪就歪了是吧
Jake: Maybe because it wasn't tightened properly, it got crooked, right?
Jake:合紧可能就好了
Jake: Tighten it, and it might be fine.
Lucia:哦你说
Lucia: Oh, you mean...
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia:尴尬
Lucia: Awkward...
Jake:不太抗地震
Jake: Not very earthquake-resistant.
Lucia: 对有可能
Lucia: Yeah, maybe.
Lucia:是啊这个地方稍微有点歪
Lucia: Yeah, this part is a bit crooked.
Lucia:是的没事
Lucia: It's okay, no worries.
Lucia:这这个这个这面就是墙
Lucia: This side, this, this side is the wall.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:你可以这样
Lucia: You can do it like this.
Lucia:就这样解决了
Lucia: Just solve it this way.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:不行把它再压压
Lucia: No, press it down again.
Lucia:能压紧一点
Lucia: Press it tighter.
Jake:压紧一点
Jake: Press it tighter.
Lucia:耶小心
Lucia: Yeah, be careful.
Lucia:因为感觉这塑料很脆的
Lucia: Because this plastic feels very fragile.
Lucia:样子我害怕太使劲给它没啥 了
Lucia: I’m afraid if we press too hard, it might break.
Jake:要摁紧一点
Jake: Need to press it tighter.
Lucia: 稍微摁紧一点 对吧
Lucia: Press it a bit tighter, right?
Jake:摁紧就得
Jake: Just press it tight.
Lucia:所以就是
Lucia: So, it’s like...
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Jake:他应该是一个扣然后摁紧就哦
Jake: There should be a clip, and then press it tight, and it will be fine.
Lucia:这样子对吧
Lucia: Like this, right?
Lucia:现在应该不会再开了
Lucia: Now it shouldn't open again.
Lucia:好了
Lucia: Alright.
Jake:我再试试
Jake: Let me try again.
Lucia:可以了我觉得
Lucia: I think it's okay.
Lucia:哈哈哈有点吓人我看看
Lucia: Hahaha, a bit scary. Let me see.
Jake:算了算了
Jake: Forget it, forget it.
Lucia:哎呀咦
Lucia: Oh no, wait.
Lucia:对就是你看他拉的时候他就会那个啥
Lucia: Yeah, when you pull it, it does that.
Lucia:就这样吧
Lucia: Just leave it like this.
Lucia:没事可以了
Lucia: It’s fine now.
Jake:它怎么一直在响
Jake: Why does it keep making noise?
Jake:我摁多少下都在响
Jake: No matter how many times I press it, it keeps making noise.
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia:没事不管了
Lucia: It's okay, never mind.
Lucia:就这样吧
Lucia: Let's just leave it like this.
Jake:挺好现在应该很稳定
Jake: It's good, it should be stable now.
Lucia:我觉得挺好可以了
Lucia: I think it's fine now.
Jake:竟然对齐了
Jake: It's aligned!
Jake:哎没对齐就这样
Jake: Oh, it's not aligned. Oh well.
Lucia:还差一点没事我觉得
Lucia: It's just a little off, it's fine.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:可能还有什么地方没有扣
Lucia: Maybe there's something not latched on properly.
Lucia:扣紧还
Lucia: Let's tighten it.
杨老板好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:好一会就可以把它搬上去了
Lucia: Alright, soon we can move it up.
Lucia:还有一个桌布
Lucia: There's still a tablecloth.
Lucia:然后铺上
Lucia: Let's spread it out.
Lucia:他会变成蓝色
Lucia: It will turn blue.
Lucia:因为我买不到蓝色的桌子
Lucia: Because I couldn't buy a blue table.
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Lucia:这个是他的轮子不安了吧
Lucia: This is its wheel, isn't it installed?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:哦麻烦死了
Lucia: Oh, this is so troublesome.
Lucia:为啥只有仨
Lucia: Why are there only three?
Lucia:应该有4个
Lucia: There should be four.
Lucia:哦谢谢
Lucia: Oh, thanks.
Jake:这挺好玩
Jake: This is pretty fun.
Lucia:那个是可心的的耳机套哦
Lucia: That's Kasen's headphone cover.
Lucia:这怎么又掉了
Lucia: Why did it fall again?
Lucia:我搁这拆家呢吧我
Lucia: Am I demolishing the house here?
Lucia:这玩意取下来安不上了
Lucia: I can't put this thing back after taking it off.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia:那应该是有个
Lucia: There should be a...
Lucia: 上面那一层和下面那一层好像
Lucia: The top layer and the bottom layer seem...
Lucia:还是不太齐哦
Lucia: ...still not quite aligned.
Lucia:算了要不然就要不然就
Lucia: Forget it, let's just leave it like this.
Lucia:就让他这样算了
Lucia: Just leave it as is.
Jake:你要拆哪个我帮你拆一下试试
Jake: Which part do you want to disassemble? I'll help you try.
Lucia:事我觉得就把他这样拼算了
Lucia: I think we should just leave it like this.
Lucia:因为可能也调整不了个啥
Lucia: Because we probably can't adjust it much.
Lucia:这咋咋插
Lucia: How do we insert this?
Lucia:我又不记得
Lucia: I don't remember.
Lucia:这对对好了
Lucia: This, yes, it's done.
Lucia:先把这放进去
Lucia: First, put this in.
Lucia:我看看这样能不能让他
Lucia: Let me see if this will work.
Lucia:就是只有中间的这个是偏偏右的
Lucia: Only the middle one is slightly to the right.
Lucia:底下两个都是都是正的
Lucia: The two at the bottom are both straight.
Jake:咖啡滤纸可能就是
Jake: The coffee filter paper is probably...
Jake:1/3次频率
Jake: ...at 1/3 frequency.
Lucia: 只有中间那个偏右
Lucia: Only the middle one is slightly to the right.
Lucia:1/3次频率行吧
Lucia: 1/3 frequency should be okay.
Jake:或者2/3次频率中间是好的
Jake: Or 2/3 frequency, and the middle one is good.
Lucia: 2/3次频率
Lucia: 2/3 frequency.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那为什么我们不把
Lucia: Then why don't we...
Lucia:果是公司2/3次
Lucia: ...if the company says 2/3 frequency...
Lucia:频率就把那个1/3那当成次品
Lucia: ...just treat the 1/3 one as a defective product.
Lucia: 我就说我设计出来就这样吧
Lucia: I'll just say I designed it this way.
Lucia: 这是我专门独创的设计
Lucia: This is my unique design.
Jake:这是要转一下 这上面是这个
Jake: This needs to be turned. This part here...
Lucia: 唉 等等
Lucia: Hey, wait a second.
Jake:这合理不
Jake: Is this reasonable?
Lucia:这这这不合理这
Lucia: This isn't reasonable.
Lucia:我买的挂布可以洗一下吗
Lucia: Can I wash the hanging cloth I bought?
Jake:可以洗
Jake: Yes, you can wash it.
Jake:我去这怎么
Jake: How does this...
Lucia:这不合理
Lucia: This isn't reasonable.
Lucia:光把说或者光把上面这个这个取下来
Lucia: Just take off this top part.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:想想它是不是观察一下
Jake: Think about it, maybe observe it.
Jake:要不把这个拆了观察一下
Jake: Or take it apart and observe it.
Lucia:这也行也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia:就要不就还是把这个这个
Lucia: Or we could just...
Jake:哎哟我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh man.
Lucia: 这合理吗
Lucia: Is this reasonable?
Lucia:呃呃
Lucia: Uh, uh.
Lucia:对不起
Lucia: I'm sorry.
Lucia:制造很多噪音
Lucia: I made a lot of noise.
Jake:这真的能开吗
Jake: Can this really open?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:应该是有一个卡扣
Jake: There should be a latch.
Jake:这个地方
Jake: Right here.
Jake:他这都卡扣的
Jake: This is all about the clips.
Jake:他怎么他怎么能让他卡扣卡进去
Jake: How can he clip it in?
Lucia:我看看啊
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake:如果这装的不对的话
Jake: If this isn't installed correctly,
Jake:怎么能让卡扣卡进去
Jake: how can he clip it in?
Jake:这根应该是扣上的
Jake: This part should be clipped in.
Jake:我感觉这边
Jake: I feel like here
Jake:是有一个凸起
Jake: there's a bump.
Lucia:哦对对对
Lucia: Oh yeah, yeah.
Lucia:有道理 嗯那这
Lucia: Makes sense. Hmm, then this
Lucia: 挂了
Lucia: is connected.
Lucia:没事 那我看看哦这个
Lucia: It's okay. Let me see, oh this
Lucia:它这里有个扣它就应该
Lucia: It has a clip here, so it should
Katrina: 你觉得呢还是说你也这样
Katrina: What do you think? Or do you also think so?
Lucia:应该也有能比如说
Lucia: It should also have something like
Shure: 我不这样啊我要真喜欢我就哭哭晚上冲
Shure: I don't think so. If I really liked it, I'd cry and rush in at night.
Lucia:怎么样能让它脱开的方法
Lucia: How can we detach it?
Lucia:就跟修玩具一样
Lucia: Just like fixing toys.
Lucia:稍等啊再放远再放远一点反正就剩一层
Lucia: Hold on, move it further, move it a bit further, there's just one layer left anyway.
Lucia:我看别太使劲把这个地方给他掰断了
Lucia: Be careful not to break this part by using too much force.
Lucia:毕竟他是个塑料主席嘛
Lucia: After all, it's just a plastic piece.
Jake:有点难
Jake: It's a bit difficult.
Lucia:嗯确实
Lucia: Yeah, indeed.
Jake:要不就
Jake: How about...
Jake:不就转一圈转一圈有用吗
Jake: Turning it around, does that help?
Lucia:应该也行吧它前后都是对称的
Lucia: It should work, it's symmetrical front and back.
Jake:反应该是这个效果啊
Jake: The effect should be the same.
Lucia: 啊对对对可以行
Lucia: Ah, yeah, yeah, it works.
Jake:它在也很有限
Jake: It's still quite limited.
Lucia: 这个要把他
Lucia: You need to...
Lucia: 对对这样就可以啦
Lucia: Yes, like this, it's fine.
Lucia: 然后这边在把它放进去就行啦
Lucia: Then just put it in here.
不Lucia: 主要它不要掉就行好了可以了
Lucia: The main thing is it doesn't fall off. Done, it's good.
Jake:好合理太合理了
Jake: Good, very reasonable.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay!
Jake:提拉米苏要干什么
Jake: What does Tiramisu want?
Jake:哎不对肉松小子要要干什么
Jake: Oh wait, what does Rou Song Xiaozi want?
Tasha:：先把东西洗了嘛
Tasha: Let's wash these things first.
Tasha:呃这些不是我的也可以不洗
Tasha: Uh, these aren't mine, so I don't have to wash them.
Tasha:就是现在还用不到
Tasha: We don't need them right now.
Jake:好我先洗我看到什么洗什么
Jake: Alright, I'll wash whatever I see first.
Jake:柯欣在干啥
Jake: What is Kexin doing?
Jake:这这是啥
Jake: What's this?
Jake:哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's fine.
Jake:露亚要不你俩做个小狗
Jake: Lucia, why don't you two make a little dog?
Lucia:可以 笔呢
Lucia: Sure, where's the pen?
Jake:笔到了一波快递哎
Jake: The pen arrived with a delivery.
Jake:咱看有没有用可以
Jake: Let's see if there's anything useful.
Lucia:哎哪一个是笔
Lucia: Hey, which one is the pen?
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Got it.
Alice:这个是别人的吗还是都可以拆
Alice: Is this someone else's or can we open it all?
Tasha:要什么笔啊
Tasha: What kind of pen do you need?
Jake:问问问问问
Jake: Ask, ask, ask.
Lucia:没事拆了之后是谁的再给谁啊
Lucia: It's okay, after we open it, we can give it to the owner.
Jake:问一问
Jake: Just ask.
Lucia:同问蹲着弄好累
Lucia: Same question, it's tiring to squat and do this.
Lucia:我们有什么吃的吗
Lucia: Do we have anything to eat?
Lucia:有点饿哎
Lucia: I'm a bit hungry.
Alice:小狗 乖乖坐着
Alice: Little dog, sit quietly.
Lucia:嗯嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Lucia:嗯我知道
Lucia: Yeah, I know.
Lucia:嗯棒棒
Lucia: Yep, good job.
Tasha:还没报呢
Tasha: It hasn't been reported yet.
Lucia:哪些是可以拆的呢
Lucia: Which ones can we open?
Jake:这咋没名字啊
Jake: Why is there no name on this?
Tasha:芋头吧
Tasha: It's probably Taro.
Tasha:我拆吧
Tasha: I'll open it.
Tasha:哦不是那我就不敢拆了
Tasha: Oh, it's not? Then I won't dare to open it.
Lucia:没事里面还有一层
Lucia: It's okay, there's another layer inside.
Jake:哇哦哎
Jake: Wow, hey.
Lucia:这好像是我的
Lucia: This seems to be mine.
Jake:好请
Jake: Alright, go ahead.
Lucia:这不是我
Lucia: This isn't mine.
Lucia:吃瓜吃到自己头上的感觉
Lucia: Feels like I'm caught in my own drama.
Lucia:好像是我的
Lucia: Seems like it's mine.
Lucia:那个什么灯
Lucia: That lamp thing.
Tasha:甜糕在哪里呢
Tasha: Where's the sweet cake?
Tasha:在外面好像
Tasha: Seems to be outside.
Alice:今天背过一个灯嗯
Alice: We carried a lamp today, right?
Alice:哦 纪念碑谷那个灯
Alice: Oh, the Monument Valley lamp.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia:我去好重哦
Lucia: Wow, this is so heavy.
Lucia:嗯好吧
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia:啊 没撕
Lucia: Ah, it’s not torn.
Alice:你来吧
Alice: You do it.
Lucia:没关系的
Lucia: It's okay.
Alice:开箱视频
Alice: Unboxing video.
Lucia:哎对哦应该录个开箱视频
Lucia: Oh right, we should record an unboxing video.
Alice:没关系我们这眼镜自带
Alice: It’s okay, our glasses come with it.
Lucia:还挺重的
Lucia: It's pretty heavy.
Lucia:比我想象的要重
Lucia: Heavier than I expected.
Lucia:我现在手这样抓他是不是会弄脏
Lucia: If I hold it like this, will it get dirty?
Lucia:管他呢
Lucia: Whatever.
Lucia:对然后就是这样
Lucia: Yeah, and then it’s like this.
Lucia:然后等到我有个蓝色的桌布
Lucia: And when I get a blue tablecloth,
Lucia:我就可以把它这样放着
Lucia: I can place it like this.
Lucia:就很就很搭
Lucia: It matches really well.
Alice:好有游戏感的 啊精油
Alice: It feels so game-like. Ah, essential oil.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:对就是它有破箱封的就有点像那个
Lucia: Yes, it has a broken seal, it’s kind of like that.
Lucia:这还有一层尼
Lucia: There’s another layer here.
Alice:哦 我去
Alice: Oh, wow.
Lucia:不过我
Lucia: But I...
Alice:这看是什么材质
Alice: Let's see what material it is.
Lucia:可能是石膏我觉得这可能是石膏浇出来的
Lucia: It might be plaster, I think it could be made of plaster.
Jake:这些笔有用吗
Jake: Are these pens useful?
Alice:这些笔
Alice: These pens?
Lucia:可以用
Lucia: They can be used.
Jake:那就用吧
Jake: Then use them.
Lucia:可以用
Lucia: They can be used.
Jake:没得哎呦你这个挺好看啥眼缘
Jake: No, oh, this looks good. What’s the attraction?
Lucia:这是一个那个灯
Lucia: This is a light.
Lucia:哎
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia:这为什么坐不住
Lucia: Why can't it sit still?
Jake:这是个灯
Jake: This is a light.
Lucia:对这是一个
Lucia: Yeah, this is a...
Lucia:那个就是小夜灯
Lucia: It’s a small night light.
Alice:这灯是买来干啥 用的
Alice: What did you buy this light for?
Lucia:就是我本来不是
Lucia: Well, originally I was...
Lucia:我本来不是打算打算买一个那个可以投影水纹的灯
Lucia: I wasn't planning to buy a lamp that can project water patterns.
Jake:别画鼻画狗脸
Jake: Don't draw a nose, draw a dog's face.
Lucia:但是水纹灯太贵了
Lucia: But the water pattern lamp was too expensive.
Lucia:然后我就决定换一个小夜灯
Lucia: So I decided to get a small night light instead.
Lucia:这后就变成了这个
Lucia: And it turned into this.
Jake:这是什么这是啥 呀
Jake: What is this?
Lucia:这是一个游戏
Lucia: This is a game.
Lucia:里这是那个游戏的场景
Lucia: This is a scene from that game.
Lucia:这个游戏叫纪念碑谷
Lucia: The game is called Monument Valley.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:我觉得你应该 听说过就是
Lucia: I think you should have heard of it.
Lucia:啊就是大概咱上高中或者刚大学那会它很火
Lucia: It was really popular around the time we were in high school or just started college.
Lucia:有是有些重比我想像的要重一些讨厌
Lucia: It is heavier than I expected, kind of annoying.
Jake:哦哟好重呀
Jake: Oh wow, it is heavy.
Lucia:对 我以为它是塑料的结果它是石膏的
Lucia: Yeah, I thought it was plastic, but it turned out to be plaster.
Jake:行那我继续洗碗
Jake: Alright, I'll keep washing the dishes.
Lucia:嗯 怎么会呢
Lucia: Hmm, how could it be?
Jake:还有个蛋呢
Jake: There's still an egg.
Jake:虽然有蚂蚁但是蚂蚁不吃东西
Jake: Even though there are ants, the ants don't eat anything.
Jake:有点奇怪
Jake: It's kind of weird.
Jake:呵它一般在实物上面可是它不去吃
Jake: Usually, they go on food, but they don't eat it.
Lucia:嗯 它是塑料的多好
Lucia: Hmm, it would be so much better if it was plastic.
Lucia:这也太重了
Lucia: This is way too heavy.
Lucia:这要粘上去
Lucia: This needs to be glued on.
Lucia:还必须要用那个粘一下才行
Lucia: We have to use that glue to stick it.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:这个盒真简单
Alice: This box is really simple.
Lucia:呃暂时还不能
Lucia: Uh, not yet.
Lucia:因为还要放东西
Lucia: Because we still need to put things in it.
Lucia:你是说做狗吗
Lucia: Are you talking about making a dog?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:其实只要那个纸够平整就可以了
Lucia: Actually, as long as the paper is smooth, it's fine.
Lucia:没事反正做了也是摆在外面
Lucia: It's okay, we're just going to put it outside anyway.
Alice:洗过澡的小狗
Alice: A bathed dog.
Lucia:看这个
Lucia: Look at this.
Lucia:咱这要是有砂纸就好了
Lucia: If we had sandpaper, that would be great.
Lucia:不过咱们这也没砂纸我也没买砂纸
Lucia: But we don't have sandpaper here, and I didn't buy any.
Lucia:我也没买砂纸
Lucia: I didn't buy sandpaper.
Lucia:不能打磨了
Lucia: We can't polish it.
Alice:剪刀在哪里
Alice: Where are the scissors?
Tasha:外面有啊
Tasha: There are some outside.
Tasha:这里也有
Tasha: And here too.
Lucia:这样比较好看
Lucia: This looks better.
Lucia:对就它
Lucia: Yes, this one.
Lucia:然后打打开就是这样的
Lucia: Then you open it like this.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Lucia:增加一些光影效果
Lucia: Add some light and shadow effects.
Lucia:virtuing things that never were and say why not
Lucia: Virtuing things that never were and say why not.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:哎好吧让我认领一个纸箱子
Lucia: Okay, let me claim a cardboard box.
Alice:有没有铅笔
Alice: Do you have a pencil?
Jake:没有铅笔可以买
Jake: No pencil, you can buy one.
Jake:美团外卖可以买
Jake: You can buy it on Meituan.
Jake:你要买吗
Jake: Do you want to buy it?
Jake:我可能还要有点别的东西买
Jake: I might need to buy some other things too.
Lucia:家里人给我打电话啦
Lucia: My family is calling me.
Lucia:我不打电话关机干啥呀
Lucia: Why would I turn off the phone if I'm not calling?
Jake:有些变化
Jake: Some changes.
Lucia:sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia:嗯让我看看最简单的
Lucia: Hmm, let me see the simplest one.
Lucia:就随便剪一下就可以
Lucia: Just cut it randomly and it will be fine.
Tasha:我来洗碗吧
Tasha: I'll wash the dishes.
Tasha:你把那个搅一下
Tasha: You stir that.
Tasha:我来交交班
Tasha: I'll take over the shift.
Jake:交班
Jake: Take over the shift.
Tasha:我把手洗一下
Tasha: I'll wash my hands.
Jake:我去厕所洗
Jake: I'll wash in the restroom.
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha:你就在这洗就行了
Tasha: Just wash here.
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What should I do?
Jake:搅和是吧
Jake: Stir it, right?
Jake:这我会
Jake: I can do that.
Lucia:咱们有胶带吧
Lucia: Do we have any tape?
Jake:有胶带多的很
Jake: We have plenty of tape.
Lucia:我好像今天还看到了一个
Lucia: I think I saw one today.
Lucia:虽然它不是透明的
Lucia: Though it's not transparent.
Lucia:但是也勉强可以用
Lucia: But it will work.
Lucia:是在哪来着呢
Lucia: Where was it?
Lucia:记得这应该
Lucia: I remember it should be...
Jake:胶带有黑胶带有双面胶
Jake: We have black tape and double-sided tape.
Lucia:呃都可以
Lucia: Uh, anything is fine.
Jake:双面胶
Jake: Double-sided tape.
Lucia:是在哪啊
Lucia: Where is it?
Lucia:我认认路线
Lucia: Let me check the route.
Jake:呃呃呃
Jake: Uh, uh, uh.
Lucia:这对
Lucia: This one.
Lucia:这好像是我今天早上看到的胶带
Lucia: This looks like the tape I saw this morning.
Lucia:只不过就是他
Lucia: It's just that it...
Lucia:他有颜色
Lucia: It has color.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia:这这是电工胶带
Lucia: This is electrical tape.
Jake:是贴是这些摄像头的也可以用
Jake: It can also be used to stick these cameras.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:这个也是双面胶
Jake: This is also double-sided tape.
Jake:我只有双面胶
Jake: I only have double-sided tape.
Jake:嗯我不对我还有黑胶带
Jake: Hmm, no wait, I also have black tape.
Jake:黑胶带在哪呢  喏
Jake: Where's the black tape? Here.
Lucia:是吧其实美纹纸也可以勉强当胶带用
Lucia: Actually, masking tape can also be used as tape.
Lucia:但他还没到
Lucia: But it hasn't arrived yet.
Lucia:嗯可能明天或者后天到
Lucia: It might arrive tomorrow or the day after.
Lucia:应该明天到然后
Lucia: It should arrive tomorrow and then...
Lucia:Excuse me
Lucia: Excuse me.
Lucia:哎是这个吗
Lucia: Hey, is this the one?
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, it is.
Lucia:我识别的多精准
Lucia: My recognition is so precise.
Lucia:就像AI一样
Lucia: Just like AI.
Jake:哈哈哈哈是
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Jake:是人均AI
Jake: Everyone is like AI now.
Jake:现在
Jake: Nowadays.
Jake:大家组建
Jake: People are assembling.
Lucia:请在下图中点击什么什么图标那种
Lucia: Please click on the icon in the image, that kind of thing.
Lucia:哈哈就为了证明你不是机器人
Lucia: Haha, just to prove you're not a robot.
Lucia:是
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:我用手
Jake: I use my hand.
Jake:我用筷子搅和是吧
Jake: I use chopsticks to stir, right?
Tasha:就是这里我拿了谢谢
Tasha: It's here, I took it, thanks.
Lucia:我了草的做一个然后
Lucia: I made a rough one and then...
Lucia:还可以细致的做一个
Lucia: I can make a detailed one.
Lucia:然后或许还可以细致的做一个
Lucia: And maybe I can make a detailed one.
Lucia:啊 可爱
Lucia: Ah, cute.
Jake:又要吃饭了是吧
Jake: Are we eating again?
Jake:又要点外卖的是吧
Jake: Ordering takeout again, right?
Jake:晚上吃什么呢
Jake: What should we have for dinner?
Lucia:都可以
Lucia: Anything is fine.
Alice:是小狗
Alice: It's a puppy.
Jake:是小狗
Jake: It's a puppy.
Jake:呵呵这
Jake: Haha, this...
Jake:我那我搜一下小狗
Jake: Let me search for puppies.
Lucia:应该系数可以说是很高了
Lucia: The coefficient can be said to be very high.
Jake:晚上吃有
Jake: For dinner, do we have...
Jake:有没有什么
Jake: Is there anything...
Jake:我们还没吃到什么
Jake: We haven't tried...
Jake:中国特色食物吗
Jake: Any traditional Chinese food?
Lucia:中国特色食物
Lucia: Traditional Chinese food.
Lucia:这是剪刀吗你再找
Lucia: Are you looking for scissors?
Alice:对对对对
Alice: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice:你觉得是头大一点还是小点
Alice: Do you think the head should be bigger or smaller?
Lucia:都可以其实你可以按着大的剪
Lucia: Either way, you can cut it larger first.
Lucia:然后剪下来再继续修改
Lucia: Then trim it down further.
Lucia:他就有调整的空间
Lucia: That way there's room for adjustments.
Jake:吃面吧
Jake: Let's have noodles.
Jake:我也不知道吃什么
Jake: I don't know what to eat.
Lucia:炸酱面
Lucia: Zhajiang noodles.
Lucia:老北京炸酱面
Lucia: Old Beijing Zhajiang noodles.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:纸板太硬了
Alice: The cardboard is too hard.
Lucia:呃瓦兰纸确实特别难剪
Lucia: Uh, valance paper is really hard to cut.
Alice:我的狗头
Alice: My dog's head.
Lucia:ok
Lucia: Ok.
Alice:这个白板笔有用吗
Alice: Is this whiteboard marker useful?
Alice:大不了用完在买
Alice: If it's used up, we can just buy more.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia:先在这里给他大概定个位吧
Lucia: Let's roughly position it here first.
Alice:这个可以用吗
Alice: Can we use this?
Lucia:哎最终竟然选了李先生牛肉面
Lucia: Hey, in the end, we chose Mr. Lee's Beef Noodles.
Jake:行不
Jake: Is it okay?
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia:定位定到这的话
Lucia: If we position it here...
Jake:这我也没吃过
Jake: I haven't tried this before.
Jake:这什么时候开的店
Jake: When did this place open?
Lucia:好早以前了
Lucia: A long time ago.
Lucia:有一段时间店很多
Lucia: There used to be a lot of stores for a while.
Lucia:然后呢这个地方先给他整个平
Lucia: So, let's level this place first.
Jake:我搅和的
Jake: Am I stirring it?
Jake:我我还得再搅和吗
Jake: Do I need to stir it again?
Tasha: 不用了
Tasha: No need.
Lucia:我怎么觉得这个耳朵
Lucia: Why do I feel like these ears...
Lucia:会显得他有点像猫呢
Lucia: ...make it look a bit like a cat?
Jake:啊你刚刚画的是狗
Jake: Weren't you drawing a dog earlier?
Lucia:对我打了个草稿
Lucia: Yeah, I made a rough sketch.
Lucia:我想把五官定一下位
Lucia: I wanted to position the features first.
Jake:哦确实挺像猫
Jake: Oh, it does look quite like a cat.
Lucia:但是发现就是对
Lucia: But then I realized, yeah...
Jake:像猫精灵
Jake: Like a cat elf.
Lucia:就是我打算
Lucia: So I plan...
Lucia:我打算换一种
Lucia: I plan to change it.
Lucia:换一种狗
Lucia: Change it to a different kind of dog.
Lucia:不是我照着这
Lucia: Not this one.
Lucia:我照着这个萨摩耶画的
Lucia: I was drawing a Samoyed.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:但是嗯
Lucia: But, um...
Lucia:大小眼睛大小应该差不多
Lucia: The size of the eyes should be about the same.
Lucia:真实话术可以往两边再
Lucia: The real technique can be adjusted...
Jake:你这狗画的挺像狗
Jake: Your dog drawing looks pretty dog-like.
Lucia:往这边在走一点好哈哈哈
Lucia: Move it a bit more this way, haha.
Tasha:啊 这挺狗
Tasha: Yeah, it's quite dog-like.
Jake:没有挺像狗
Jake: No, it's very dog-like.
Jake:挺像狗
Jake: Very dog-like.
Lucia:对那就这样
Lucia: Alright, let's go with that.
Jake:好嘞来请
Jake: Okay, go ahead.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Sure.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:行那就把它改成这样吧
Lucia: Alright, let's change it to this.
Jake:点菜点菜
Jake: Let's order some food.
Lucia:然后一会在调整一下
Lucia: We can adjust it later.
Jake:百忙之中点俩菜
Jake: Order a couple of dishes amidst our busy schedule.
Jake:我要干什么呢
Jake: What should I do now?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Tasha:包上就行
Tasha: Just wrap it up.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia:现在就用蓝色这个定位应该差不多
Lucia: Using the blue one for positioning should be about right.
Lucia:差不多的话
Lucia: If it's about right,
Lucia:从这走
Lucia: go from here.
Lucia:从这走然后
Lucia: Go from here and then...
Lucia:这走这走
Lucia: Go this way, this way.
Lucia:差不多这么个大小然后
Lucia: About this size, then...
Lucia:看看大家点的什么
Lucia: Let's see what everyone ordered.
Lucia:我就要个招牌牛肉面吧
Lucia: I'll just have the signature beef noodles.
Lucia:我好了
Lucia: I'm done.
Lucia:您点了吗
Lucia: Did you order?
Jake:我也是招牌牛肉面啊
Jake: I'll also have the signature beef noodles.
Jake:有人不是招牌牛肉面吗
Jake: Did anyone not order the signature beef noodles?
Lucia:不知道哎
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia:不知道啊
Lucia: No idea.
Jake:吃什么呀
Jake: What are you eating?
Lucia:可以 咦
Lucia: Okay, eh?
Lucia:哎那个薇薇的地毯上也是这个小狗
Lucia: Hey, Tasha's carpet also has this little dog.
Lucia:好可爱好像是一个动画
Lucia: So cute, it's like a character from a cartoon.
Lucia:动画人物吧
Lucia: A cartoon character, right?
Lucia:对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia:好像是一个动画人物
Lucia: It's like a cartoon character.
Lucia:good
Lucia: Good.
Lucia:眼睛这个定位觉得还可以
Lucia: The eyes' positioning seems okay.
Alice:有双面胶之类的吗
Alice: Do we have double-sided tape or something?
Jake:有有双面胶
Jake: Yes, we have double-sided tape.